I'm joined today in what I think will be
a very very interesting interview by
Reed Summers who's the director of the
Society for the new message from God
he's the son of the messenger Marshall V
on summers I'm so fascinated read by
everything you guys have going on over
there if for people who aren't familiar
first of all with the Society for the
new message from God is this a church
within a religion is it a religion in
and of itself how do you describe it
well first and foremost it is a new
message from God it is a communication
from the creator of all life for people
of all religions and people of no
religion so first and foremost it is a
message it is also a worldwide community
and a movement worldwide amongst men and
women in over 106 countries at this
point well who are undertaking a return
to their own natural innate spirituality
and seeking to find their own unique
contribution to a world in need and what
does that mean in terms of the sort of
physical manifestation is there a
physical building of Prayer that that
exists or is this sort of a loosely an
amorphous community with with people
spread out throughout the world as you
mentioned in over a hundred countries
people spread out around the globe you
know we we are based in Boulder Colorado
yeah but we have people everywhere
around the world our works are
translated into over 23 languages and we
gather global worldwide so it's a
worldwide movement of people really
rising up at this time of unbelievable
challenge conflict and division yeah in
our world rising up to make their own
unique contribution inspired by the
spiritual power which lives within them
and lives within all people so you're
not you are not a Christian organization
no we are not we're not we are a new
revelation a new message from the
creator of all life and God is open
again yeah that's what I want to get
into so this this entire thing sort of
started around the time that you were
born roughly speaking
your father was was contacted by God is
that the way that it that it was well 33
years ago my father was called into the
deserts of the American Southwest by an
angelic presence that had been growing
in his awareness
for years up to that point and at that
moment in the desert that presence
overcame him spoke through him right and
instructed him to record and was in any
kind of hallucinogenics at this time no
no he was you know he was actually a
teacher for blind children Oh before
that time
yep he was simply this this simply began
to emerge in his life over the course of
years and culminated in this encounter
in the desert when he was instructed to
record and in the years since he has
done so and this voice of revelation has
spoken through him in over 800 angelic
encounters and in so doing has delivered
a new message from the creator of all
life for all people speaking on almost
every imaginable aspect of world need
and personal need and why why your
father in other words why was your
father the recipient of such a message
well the new message from God says that
my father was sent from the angelic
assembly into the world to prepare to
receive a pure and complete
communication from God to humanity Wow
he is a man you know he has a human
nature he has a pretty amazing story
challenging life journey he's taken and
it's not like for example where Jesus
some Christians believe Jesus to be the
sort of embodiment of God on our planet
your dad is just a normal Homo sapiens
he is a man in the world absolutely he
has a mind and a body and a human nature
he's an immensely grounded why is
compassionate human being and yet there
is something else as I think you and
your viewers would would perhaps be able
to see if you were to meet him I think
there is something else a deeper
spiritual fire that he carries that
ignites people that moves and empowers
people Wow is this I want to ask this
question delicately but I think it's an
important question for anybody who after
this interview is going to go and
research your organization there's
questions about whether it is a cult and
I hesitate to use that term only because
it's a turn
that could be defined in so many
different ways so maybe we could attack
it from a couple of specific angles do
you encourage the followers of the
organization to sort of separate from
family and friends who may not accept
what it is that are the teachings of
your father is that something that the
followers are encouraged to do
absolutely not no I mean we we are
people who have families extended
families we live in Muslim nations
Christian nations secular nations and we
are people who seek to bring the spirit
of this revelation which is really the
spirit at the heart of all religions
right and and moves in people who have
no religion we attempt to bring that
spirit into our families and and that is
the spirit of you know love and
compassion and forgiveness the ability
to listen to another and really
understand them and really get them so
in no way are we focused on separating
from this world we're focused on being
in this world but inspired at a deeper
level I've read with endless fascination
some of the instances you've recalled
from your childhood including as young
as ten years old and and you have this
story which I don't want to tell for you
but the story I'm referencing just to
jog your memory is when you press your
ear up against the door of your dad's
room and you you both heard and felt
something right I was just thinking
about this the other day
actually yeah tiptoeing on all fours up
the stairs at the age of 10 because I
heard a voice upstairs and it was not
the voice of my father well and going up
to the door pressing the ear to the door
and hearing this voice and I encouraged
you know you and your listeners to go
hear this voice because for the first
time in history the voice that spoke to
the messengers of the past in the desert
in a cave at a burning bush has been
recorded and is available for all people
to hear and you believe that is the god
courageous well this is the voice this
is the voice of revelat what we call the
voice of revelation boca it is the will
and intention of God beyond language
being communicated by the angelic
presence through the messenger so it is
the voice of the angelic assembly now
why do you need to sneak up in other
words was that supposed to be a private
moment between
revealer and your dad and you sort of
were like a fly on the wall or
interrupted the party so to speak to use
a rather crude analogy or why were you
just not included in that to begin with
do you think well you know every angelic
encounter has been recorded in its
original audio and as a kid I think I
was sensitive to the fact that I was
stomping and romping around the house
and throwing things and making general
noise and ruckus at a time at a moment
when something really important was
happening and I could feel as a child
this pervasive importance this
consequence is gravity that my parents
carried being that they're very humble
people my mother was a nurse for decades
supporting my father you know my father
is a very even you know man of real kind
of solid and substance and and so
they're not extraordinary extravagant
people and yet here we are having a
normal family life and I'm a
ten-year-old and I could feel the
importance almost fill the home you know
pervade the space and so tiptoeing up
there to here I think was was I just
innately kind of knew I should not you
know stomp up the stairs to here has
this has this work of this is gospel I
don't know if that's the right term but
has this gospel that your father and and
now you are sort of putting out there
for the world has this made you guys
very very wealthy no not at all
my mother retired from her nursing
profession two years ago my father took
no compensation for decades yeah
absolutely not in any way and I mean
this is this is an effort to bring a
message of activation activating the
human heart to people at a very painful
desperate time in the world and I think
given the events of last week you know
the world is roiling in this feeling of
anxiety and confusion and frustration
because I'm feeling out of that now for
sure i I'm sure you are in I mean maybe
what we're feeling is here we are at
this amazing cusp in the world where
climate change is accelerating human
mass migration is sweeping continents
okay we have an environmental calamity
on our hands and yet humanity has not
come to get
they're sat down at the table and
cooperated sufficiently yeah no doubt I
I think yeah and and really what the new
message is here to do is to call forth a
greater good in the human family so it
sounds like I mean you're getting into
some political issues there are it does
your organization take a view on
something as earthly as gay marriage for
example or the medical procedure known
as abortion are those things that you
guys take a position on or that God has
through your dad as you mentioned well
the new message supports and advocates
certain things in the world doesn't call
call for exact policies but it does
honor and recognize individuals who have
a gay orientation and says that gay
relationships can possess a higher
purpose and meaning long resonance with
individuals that is not like most
religious folks that I've spoken to I'll
tell you that this is a new revelation
it is new and it is fresh and it is
renewed and it is not denigrating anyone
it honors and respects the existing
faiths and their communities and says
that they and their faith tradition are
part of God's ongoing plan to serve the
world well and so this is not about
creating an elite group and you know
that that is going to be redeemed and
saved and empowered above all others
yeah this is about calling everyone back
to the heart of their spirituality of
their tradition even if they had no
tradition yeah so that the good can come
from too many places to be stopped in
the world
hey last thing I want to touch on in the
limited time we have is there any sort
of rapture or Apocalypse prediction
through the messenger that you guys have
received from from God the new message
from God this is not the end of times no
message makes that clear this is the
beginning of a transition to a different
kind of new world reality a world of
declining resources a world where
cooperation and unity and compassion
have got to be paramount and so there is
great urgency in the new message make no
mistake it is it is speaking in no
uncommon terms of the global crisis in
which we live yeah and yet no there is
no end times there's no chosen time when
certain people will be elevated
beyond others the human family goes on
and the question is in what spirit does
it go on yeah how unified is it and are
we going to continue to degrade and
plunder the world threatening the very
foundations of human civilization Wow
well Reid Sommers you've said it all I
don't know what I could possibly add to
this you really have director of the
Society for the new message from God I
think our audience will really have a
lot to look into after this interview
and I really do thank you for talking to
us about the new message and I for one
found it absolutely fascinating thank
you so much thank you David appreciate
you having